thank you thank you very much everybody
thank you please sit down and welcome to
mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom yeah like
a beautiful crowd and we're gonna be
doing something a little different today
we're gonna be taping the show from my
backyard where I have a bar and what did
you expect it's my house I have a bar
would you expect to see here at child's
play pen
but I tell you is this really what it's
come to that I'm going to be shot on an
iPhone I feel like an entree at the
Cheesecake Factory
I mean I want to go out but Gavin Newsom
says I'm grounded
and I am grounded and I have the blue
balls to prove it but I'm telling you I
am practicing every safe directive they
say I should I make sure I use
disinfectant on every surface that has
at least 60% alcohol like judge Jeanine
Pirro I stay six feet away from
strangers eight from Charlie Sheen and
I'd say that this is not a bad idea that
staying six feet away from people I say
next we try it with cars well you know
for Los Angeles people I tell you the
worst part of this is seeing that the
highways are completely empty but
there's nowhere to go I mean some people
are looking at porn at home I'm looking
at I'm looking at photos of the 405 with
no cars on them
but it is getting a little grim around
here I have to admit yesterday the
highlight of my day was wiping down the
mailman my stalker was working from home
but thank you Jesus I have no symptoms
unless you count [ __ ] my pants every
time Trump talks
[Applause]
I tell you I am starting to wonder if
he's really a doctor the other day a
reporter asked him about South Korea why
they're doing better than we are and he
said I knew everything about South Korea
you know how many people there are in
Seoul South Korea 38 million
okay there's 10 million people in Seoul
South Korea
if Trump played celebrity jeopardy
cancer would go bankrupt and then he
does this thing every day where he's
bragging about his ratings at better
ratings in Monday Night Football The
Bachelor yes because your viewers aren't
allowed to leave the house well what
else are they gonna do read your your
saying mr. president every day
information that people need that could
be instrumental to saving their life
anything less than a hundred chair means
people hate you more than they love life
so look we're gonna get through this we
are and stress it's the worst thing for
your immune system so try to think a
little positive think about all the
celebrities who have this that we know
have this Center doing okay Prince
Charles Tom Hanks Jackson Browne quiz
Chris Cuomo Kevin Durant
anybody who's anybody's getting it
and you know tom tom hanks of course was
so classy when he got it he said it's an
honor just to be contaminated and in the
movie the person who cures Tom Hanks
will be played by Tom Hanks
[Applause]
you